[Music]
hello
welcome everyone to our deferred
enrollment at the gsb
session we're really fortunate to be
joined by some of our current students
and alumni who have actually come to
stanford through our deferred enrollment
program
so we're going to spend the majority of
our time today talking with them
about their decision to pursue deferred
enrollment and
pursue their mba here at stanford but
before we do that
i want to ground us a little bit today
with you because ultimately the most
important person in this whole process
is you and the decision to pursue a
graduate degree in business
and ultimately where will start with you
you are going to decide what the next
phase of your journey will be
it's your goal to decide that
what will drive you forward it's our
goal to help you achieve those goals
whatever they might be and a lot of
goals
started here at stanford and became
something much bigger
so i'd like to tell you a little bit
about our approach
to management education here at stanford
so at stanford we encourage you to
expand your mindset opening yourself up
to new points of view
possibilities opportunities
we try to ground you in thinking about
how to think boldly
helping you approach problems with a
fresh perspective
and get them and get to the most
innovative solutions
we try to help you build your community
meeting people who will encourage and
inspire you
from classmates to faculty to alumni and
business leaders
we'll try to teach you to lead from the
heart finding your personal leadership
style
that will ultimately help you lead
authentically
and ethically playing to both your
strengths and your values
and we want to help you define the
future
not just the shape of your own personal
future but the future of your
organization
and maybe even the future of the world
so it's a little bit about the stanford
mba
but i want to ground us a little bit
right now in
deferred enrollment what is it how does
it work
so for us here at stanford the what
is that deferred enrollment will allow
you to apply for early admission to
business school
and then gain professional experience
before starting your mba
when do you do it well it looks like
many of you have already figured this
part out
you'll be applying in the final year of
your bachelor degree
or while you're enrolled in a graduate
program that you began
immediately following your undergraduate
program
how does it work well you'll select your
preferred enrollment year in your mba
application there is no separate
application
for deferred enrollment you'll actually
use the same mba application
as those that are applying for direct
enrollment this year
and as a deferred candidate you'll have
the opportunity and the option to defer
anywhere from one
to four years and if you are eligible
for a deferred enrollment
you will pay a reduced application fee
of 100
so that's a very high level overview
of what deferred enrollment is but this
is really just the very beginning
of your journey so we encourage you to
check out mystanford.mba
where you'll be able to take a short
quiz that will allow you to
create a personalized dashboard where
you can keep track of your application
progress
find out about upcoming events and other
information
about stanford that is ultimately very
tailored for you
and your interests so i encourage you to
continue to engage with our school and
and join us for other events that we may
be hosting from our information sessions
to our meet and admission officer or
meet a student
sessions that we are hosting regularly
these days for right now i'd really like
us to focus
on spending some time with our panel
because these are students who've gone
through the deferred enrollment process
and we hope that hearing from them will
allow you
to better prepare for what's next for
you
so with that i would like to turn things
over to
our wonderful panel today i'm going to
give everyone just a minute to
digest this introduction panel here and
then we're going to actually hear from
everyone directly
uh so i'm going to turn things over to
our panel right now
and ask each of you uh to go right in
order that we can see your names here on
the screen
and rather than just repeating some of
the things that we can see here i'd love
for you to share your name
what you studied in undergrad and
how long your deferral period was before
you joined us at stanford
and we'll do intros with this slide and
then we'll stop sharing that slide and
turn things over completely to the panel
today
so anseman take it away
hi everyone thank you for joining us
today um my name is alan schmann i was
class of 15
at the gsb my undergrad was in
industrial engineering
at purdue with a minor in math and
i was deferred for two years so i
applied right out of college in 2011 and
then matriculated
in 2013 graduated in 2015.
wonderful hi everyone thanks so much for
joining us today
i'm a current mba one pursuing a dual
degree with the kennedy school
i graduated from dartmouth college in
2017
with a degree in government and human
centered design
and my deferral period of time was three
years
hi everyone i'm jisha i'm an mba two to
graduating
june i went to cornell from my undergrad
studied
computer science um and my and just
first before years before coming to the
and my name is devin uh i was class of
2018
at the university of missouri i was
class of 14 studying math economics and
statistics and so got in then
started gsb uh in 16 uh
i yeah and i'm
excited to chat with you all we do
unfortunately have to let gisha go
a little early today because she's
heading into an evening class
so we will certainly try to to get as
many questions to her earlier on before
she has to go
so i'm going to turn this over to uh
anshuman
and then darren greenberg i'd love to
hear
from your perspectives because you have
two different undergraduate
backgrounds uh tell me a little bit
about why you decided to pursue
graduate school of business uh an mba
program
well i'll go first so for me
a big theme of my interest and something
that i'm deeply passionate about
is how we as a society
collaborate and coordinate and a big
part of that you know given that we're
in silicon valley today is
technology but another part of it is
management you know how do you get one
plus one
to yield three right um and so with that
as a big focus i realized
that that's where an mba could be pretty
powerful
because i think it effectively
accelerates and jump starts
the learning perhaps you might already
have gotten right um
if for example if you want to build and
scale businesses which is
what i want to do um you can't always do
that in a classroom but you can maximize
the probability and the likelihood of
that happening
because you're jump starting your
education there and specifically i think
the gsb played a big role for me because
you know it really provided three big
things one um
a diverse set of peers that i could
learn from
an interdisciplinary environment because
i think that's the reality of
businesses and organizations that we're
in today and then finally
and most importantly a practitioner-led
curriculum
you know i think my experience with my
classes was that
over 50 percent of my classes were
practitioner-led which was
uh incredible and so that's why i chose
an mba and a stanford md in particular
great and i'll build on that um i always
like to say
i didn't really choose to pursue an mba
i chose to pursue an mba at stanford
um and i really feel that to be true um
and by
by applying as a deferred admit i had
the luxury of doing so with no real
downside um and there were two primary
reasons that that
drove that choice um the first is that i
had a hypothesis at that point
that i wanted to be a leader one day in
federal government
and specifically to drive design-led
innovation in that space
so the first reason was really about
getting this wonderful cross-sector
management toolkit
as entrepreneur referred to i think
stanford is pretty distinctively
positioned to
to give you that um and the second
reason was more about
stanford holistically as a university
and its strength
in design so specifically the d school
here um and i was just so
excited about diving into the d-school
classes through my mba
um yeah fantastic
so next question is going to be for
devon kelsey and jisha
when you were thinking about applying
what led you to the
deferred enrollment path versus maybe
working for a few years and then
applying
so jisha maybe we'll start with you sure
um i think like what devin was saying
that
there wasn't any real downside to
applying while i was in college and i
think
that was the driver while there is an
opportunity i wanted to
take advantage of it um
and it all i also felt like
i was convinced enough that an mba would
be helpful to me down the road
um i was just doing cs i had a job lined
up as a software engineer
and i knew i loved building technology
products but i wanted to learn how to
build technology businesses down the
road and
so it's just a question of why wait if
there's an opportunity to
apply now um and then i always thought
oh
if it doesn't work out i can always
apply lawyer too
yeah i didn't know a lot about mba
programs when i started the process
but i saw it as a very similar to as
both the last two speakers said
just a why not question um i didn't
think i could get into a school like
stanford candidly
but i figured why not apply to some of
my reach schools now
and i thought in a world where i didn't
get in i was comfortable with that
because i was like the normal world
is waiting a few years and then applying
and so i can always wait until then and
apply
to not just my reach schools but the
ones i thought i had more of a chance of
getting in
and i was lucky enough to to apparently
get into one of my reach schools
thanks everyone so one of the first
questions coming into us was about
choosing recommenders so the question
was asking
you know how how do you choose a
recommender so if you're coming maybe
with some
limited full-time professional work
experience
how do you select your recommenders we
provide some guidance on
our website but curious to maybe hear
from one or two of you
about your process for selecting a
recommender
um so devon greenberg maybe we'll direct
this question to you did you
select internship supervisors
supervisors who maybe worked with you at
student clubs or organizations
maybe share with the group today a
little bit about how you thought
about that yeah absolutely um i think
there's no wrong answer there
in terms of it being an internship
supervisor or maybe a professor you did
research for
for me personally i went with two
professors one government one
and one human centered design one uh
both of whom i had ta'ed for
and so who had like direct uh experience
with my work and could speak to that
pretty pretty precisely i think more
broadly
as i was approaching the application
process i was trying to think about the
broader story
i was trying to tell um and
you know what would be cohesive with my
essay
with my resume with the portrait i was
trying to paint in
in the info i wanted to share with the
admissions committee um
so when i was translating that to the
recommender choice it was really like
who knows me best who understands my
story best and
who do i think can convey that well um
yeah
yeah some really good advice there so
the next
question is can you change your mind
about when you want to enroll
after you get in so for example in your
application if you indicate
u1a to your deferral and then you want
to maybe start
later the answer is yes you do have a
lot of flexibility
you can request or say that you want to
come in one or two years
and then at that point in time we
actually check in with you
and ask if you want one more year or two
more years
uh essentially you have a lot of wiggle
room up until that maximum
of four years so jisha i know you
actually
took the the long route and actually
decided to extend your deferral through
the maximum
four years could you maybe share with
the group a little bit about what led to
that decision
yeah sure so um i got in
with a two-year deferral period i forget
if i
picked that or if that was standard at
the time um
and then every year i just
reconsidered that this was the time to
go to stanford
and was able to defer one year at a time
until
four years before i came here and the
reason for that was i was working as a
software engineer and had an
opportunity to try out a product
management rule internally
um and that that switch was
a challenging process internally and i
um
since i had a shot at it i really wanted
to explore that role and i think
i i felt like switching roles trying
something different would also give me
more breadth of experience before coming
to the gst
and so in order to a have the
opportunity to pursue that and
b gain that extra experience
i then deferred from two to four years
and i i thought that was a pretty good
time for me to
leave and come to stanford great
thank you devon kelsey on the counter
you opted for the two-year path do you
want to share a little bit about
how you made that decision that that was
the right time for you
yeah i mean candidly i was so excited to
come
i would have come the moment i could but
i got a two-year deferral
uh when i got in which i think was
somewhat standard
for college seniors at the time when i
applied to mba programs i didn't even
know deferral was a thing
and at the time i didn't quite
understand it but i was really glad i
went through it in hindsight
because even looking back at who i was
as a college senior applying for
business school
thinking i was ready and thinking i had
so many questions answered
two years in the workplace really helped
change that and really helped make me
into a person that
i was in a much better place starting
business school about knowing who i
wanted to be
that said i think if they'd given me the
option to come the day after i got in i
would have done so
thank you so with a longer lens uh
antimon this question is for you now
that you've graduated
what benefits have you seen in applying
to
the deferred enrollment path to mba from
undergrad
now that you have a few years under your
belt post mba
yeah um for me the deferral was all
about hypothesis testing i think devon
mentioned that as well uh
so for me you know one of the questions
i was grappling with
out of undergrad is you know thinking
about
being in the private sector versus the
public sector and i think like that
deferral
basically gave me an opportunity to test
that hypothesis one year at the time i
did so for two years
i think that was really powerful because
i think it gave me
a concrete data point on which path i
want to pursue because
after that i was i recognized that i
want to go down the private sector and
that's been immensely helpful for me
since then
um if anything you know maybe i would
have probably different ban out of the
year
um in in hindsight just to test a few
more hypotheses but
but you know i have no regrets and i
think um i'm very grateful and happy
that gsb allowed me to do this because
again back when i think to devon's point
like back when i i was applying i don't
think deferred enrollment was a thing
and uh i was very lucky that that was
even an option
available for me yeah you brought up
an important note i think for many of
our attendees today in that
stanford one was one of the first
schools to offer this deferred
enrollment path
to the nba but in recent years it's
becoming
more and more prevalent and more and
more programs are starting to roll out
this option
so naturally one of the questions we're
getting right now is
what are the benefits of deferred
enrollment so
you've highlighted one already which is
sort of to test some hypotheses
uh during that time but uh jia could you
share maybe
some of the other benefits that you
found especially since you gave yourself
a little more time
during that deferral were there other
benefits of
that time that you spent before you came
into the mba that you found really
valuable
yeah i think um this goes back to when i
was a senior in college
and applied it it was something that i
thought
i wanted to invest in myself i wanted to
just broadly uh
move closer to the business side of
things
because i was on the deep tech side of
things and it was a very
broad sort of argument i had in my head
but the four years
really helped me talk to alumni talk to
people and understand why i truly wanted
to
pursue an mba at stanford particularly
it also helps me
um plan out the hypotheses
what i'm saying that i wanted to test
and kind of
um helps me get there faster that i
think i would have otherwise if i had
just gone into my full-time role
and just have life played course um
it also helped me plan financially
because i knew that like nba was coming
up potentially coming up
so um all those three reasons i think it
was it was helpful to
to have that life plan already set out
all right so just checking the q a and i
see one question that has gotten
up voted quite a few times which is what
made you choose
stanford out of all programs so devin
greenberg i know you mentioned that it
was not so much about
i want an mba but specifically it was i
want an mba from stanford could you
maybe elaborate a little bit by what you
meant by that yeah absolutely um
there are so many pieces to it but i
think the big ones that stand out to me
are one uh the emphasis on interpersonal
skills
um we have so much like curricular and
extracurricular opportunity
to develop our soft skills um and the
way we
relate to others make them feel seen and
heard
um yeah and just integrate that into our
leadership styles and
that has like really been true to my
experience so far
um the second was definitely the design
school at stanford
um and the ways that has impacted my
experience
um which i can speak to more if people
are interested
um and then the third was yeah
definitely the emphasis
on cross-sector management social
innovation
conceived of across sectors um and
especially the opportunity to meet and
collaborate with people who
saw things the same way and wanted to
think interdisciplinary
great speaking of interdisciplinary
we've had a few questions about
joint degrees and dual degrees uh and
how you apply to those
as a deferred candidate so i'll answer
broadly speaking with the admissions
head on
in that you'd apply for deferred
enrollment to the mba
now and then ideally you would be
applying to
the other programs during your first
year in the mba
that is true for most of our joint
degree programs
at stanford um a couple of exceptions
though
or something and i can maybe have devin
again pile on here
um harvard kennedy school we do actually
have a partnership
where you can do a joint study program
with their mpp or mpa
programs and you can actually apply to
harvard kennedy during your final year
of your deferral
because ultimately you do have the
choice for where to begin your studies
uh devin i believe you've joined us
first some of your classmates are
starting their studies at hks and then
will come to us
after that do you want to share briefly
a little bit about your decision to
apply to that graduate program and
pursue the joint path
which is something you probably decided
during your deferral
yeah i i was really excited about the
combination
of experiences and communities
something that drew me about hks was the
opportunity to
be a student alongside many people who
had worked in government and maybe could
speak to the spaces in which
i might want to serve one day and i
think that the hksgsb
dual degree program is really special in
the sense that
you have a very strong cohort um and i
know that that's really true in my class
like people who are planning out the
logistics of their courses
and their timeline all together um and
so that makes it like
much more seamless than one might expect
from the outset and to be a really
meaningful experience
great i'm going to knock out a quick
tactical question
uh we're getting a lot of questions and
interest in how large
the cohort is for deferred enrollment
and i think that's something that is
unique to stanford's program is
we don't necessarily have a cutoff or
our number that we're aiming for each
year
because of the flexibility of the
program where you can come anytime in
one to four years
we don't necessarily restrict how many
offers we make in a given year
uh it is really based on how many people
are applying each year and
and who is applying and when uh and
ultimately we are just
looking for the the strongest candidates
we can find that are going to contribute
to this community
so those numbers will fluctuate from
year to year uh and i know for all of
the students and and alums
uh the number of deferred students in
the class uh
varies quite a bit from year to year so
it really just depends when people
make the decision for themselves that
it's the right time
uh to come so uh devin you mentioned
uh some of the benefits kind of
extracurricular and interdisciplinary
that exist here at stanford uh
turning things over to antimon and devin
kelsey wondering if each of you could
share maybe some favorite
memories of organizations or activities
or classes that you got involved with
during your time at stanford
that can maybe highlight some of that
i'll go um
so one one of my fondest memories uh
from the gsb was
actually taking a class at the law
school um you know i think the law
school is one of the top
top rate you know top uh law schools in
the country
and they actually i don't know if they
still do but
back in the day they had a class called
thinking like a lawyer specifically for
uh i think non-lawyer or non-uh law
school students and it was exceptional
you know i think every class was
basically a primer on
the things that i needed to know um from
a legal standpoint of starting a
business but also how to think
like a lawyer right like a very
structured um
analytical approach to thinking really
enjoyed that i think as devon mentioned
the d school is really strong
so we um so so i know a lot of my
classmates actually took some really
interesting classes and they've been
really successful businesses that have
actually come out of
some of these classes
other than that i think the the
engineering school
was was a pretty powerful one i think we
actually had a negotiations
class that's taught as a cross class
between the engineering school
and the business school which is really
interesting because i think it has a
much more
quantitative uh analytical approach to
how you think about negotiations
so again like i'm a big fan and i think
if i'm not wrong like pretty much
most of the departments at stanford are
one of the top
uh rated uh departments in the country
so you know that speaks to something
uh in answering i'll shift a little bit
more to the extracurricular side
and note that i would be remiss to not
use the
the easiest fruit to grab here which is
gsb talk
which i think every panelist always
waits for who's going to be the first
one to grab that as the easy thing to
chat about
um if you're not familiar with gsb talk
it's a program where students go
up um and it's an extracurricular thing
that happens in the evenings and
students go up and
just share their life story with the
rest of their classmates and most of the
class sits there and listens and
these are often very personal and very
deep like in my case it was sharing
the background of the death of my mother
and my problematic relationship with her
and the power of having a class and a
community of people who you respect
as intellectuals you respect as leaders
but also like
care about and love to like sit there
and cry with you
as you tell your personal story to them
is just something i mean like the other
devin said like
applying to mba is different than
applying
to mba at stanford in some sense because
there is just something so unique
about the extracurricular which ties in
with the curricular in so many ways
but there's just something so different
about the community there
and i wouldn't have traded it for the
world
thanks devin uh and as an aside our
other
devon is actually a talk coach which is
a leadership opportunity that you can
hold
at stanford so uh just something to keep
in mind
uh jisha i'm going to turn things over
to you a
very popular question is actually from
anvita
who is asking about the career search so
as a college senior oftentimes your
career path is not set in stone
so how did you define that pathway for
yourself as you were thinking about your
career in your application uh you know
did you have a clear goal at the time
and
maybe tell us a little bit about your
career search and
how it's evolved during your time in the
program
yes yes of course the million dollar
question
um so when i was applying to the gsb
um as i was sharing earlier heading into
my
full-time role as a software engineer
i'm very happy about it
um i did have a sense that years down
the line i might want to do
something different and i always had a
dream of starting something
starting a business um and was always
excited about the technology space and
wanted to
like knew that i'd be i'd be there for
ever
um coming to i think
between applying and coming to the gsc
i came across product management while
working with product managers
and i realized i really enjoyed that
role wanted to try it out and
ended up switching and getting some
experience there before coming to the
gst
i fell in love with product management
so i came into the gst
knowing i want to stay in the tech
industry i love
product management and i still have this
dream of starting
so at something gsc i took a lot of
entrepreneurship
courses um tried to meet
people in my class and find people with
um
shared interests and explore ideas
together which has been
really great at the gst um i'm not
starting before people ask i'm not
starting a company
right now i'm thinking of joining a
growing startup
that remains um something i'd love to do
down the line
um i also explored the venture capital
industry that was something i was
curious about
i um i knew that the world startups in
the venture capital industry are very
intertwined
and out of um the hypotheses i wanted to
test that was kind of top
uh up there so i did some part-time work
and internships to try and understand
that world better
um but eventually now that i'm heading
into my last quarter
i i know that i'm going to um
pursue product roles at growing tech
stardust
in the valley um so the part of your
question which was
how did you chart out that path i think
it's just evolved every single
quarter um a lot of the explorations and
classes and part-time work have um
really um influenced how i think about
my
career a lot of the interpersonal
dynamics such as really and classes
where um i deeply connect with my peers
and understand what they're thinking
and and process what i want in life
um those have been really helpful to
figure out like what i
really want when i'm 90 years old and
look back on my life
and so a combination of all of those
have
constantly evolved and gotten me to
where i am now where i have some sense
of what i want to do right after
and maybe some sense of where i want to
end up
wonderful thank you so for this next
question i'm going to open it up to
whoever feels like they might be able to
chime in with some examples
a really popular question here about how
important is social impact
and sustainability at stanford gsb could
any of you
describe opportunities to get involved
in these areas
so is there anyone here on the panel who
can speak a little bit about
either the center for social innovation
uh
or or one of those areas or unique
opportunities that exist here at
stanford if anyone in particular
actually took advantage of any of those
we'd love to hear that um
yeah so definitely has been core to
according to my experience thus far
um one of the opportunities i've
appreciated most since i started in the
fall
was the center for social innovations
peer groups
um and so what's beautiful about this
opportunity is that you have a little
cohort of
fellow students who care about social
impact or having
having a positive impact with their
careers and are conceiving of completely
different ways of approaching that
be it through the private public or
social sectors
and are actually collaborating and
supporting one another and
thinking through those journeys and so
that has been
a very helpful and very meaningful um
aspect of social social impact at the
gsb for me
um a second resource or opportunity that
springs to mind
was actually started by my class um and
we just call it the public sector
innovation club and what it is in
practice
is students who are thinking about
pivoting towards government or towards
something government adjacent after
graduation
and are you know bringing together our
networks resources and experiences
to support one another and thinking that
through um
and so that's been wonderful as well um
but i would say just more broadly like
sustainability government um energy like
in whatever domain that you're
passionate about social impact i can
pretty confidently say that
there are classmates and there are
resources with which to pursue that
great thank you i've got my eye on the
clock and i know we're about to lose
gisha so before you go another popular
question
what have you enjoyed the most about
studying at stanford
it could be a particular class or the
culture
is there something that you're certainly
going to take with you after graduation
yeah it comes down to people people
people the professors
my peers but what i will take the
opportunity to call out here is the
arbuckle fellows program
it's been the most uh meaningful part of
my stanford experience
um for those who aren't familiar it's
um it's a program where second year mbas
learn how to coach and develop others
and work with
first-year mbas um for over a
two-quarter long period
and that's been a really fulfilling um
experience i've seen a lot of growth
through that so
definitely one of my favorites great
well thank you again for joining us
today
uh good luck in class this evening
thanks for being here
uh we're gonna kind of piggyback off of
that another popular question we've
gotten
uh what has been the most memorable or
what was the most memorable
community building moment you had at the
gsb
so devon kelsey i'm going to give that
one to you
yeah i'm going to tell about one of my
favorite organizations
at gsb which is gsb show
it is something i was very involved in
but it is
exactly what it sounds like a musical
theater show that
the business school puts on and it is a
fully original three-hour production
with actors
dancers the whole like but what really
makes it like an interesting thing for
the community
is how much like people are lovingly
teasing out like the somewhat ridiculous
things of your own community but like
poking fun at yourselves
um and especially like having fun like
showing
in the end what you love about the
school um it's like the highest attended
event
at the business school like the dean
himself always comes and likes
sits front and center and there's so
many faculty members there and just
about everybody in the class comes
and it's like a really powerful bonding
experience by the end because
without a doubt every year it ends on
this note of like some
song about how lucky we are to have this
community of the gsb
and it becomes like a very defining a
night for the evening for
both those who are involved on it but
all the students who
go to go to support it as well
wonderful thanks for sharing uh anshimon
question for you from
carolyn how has stanford shaped you
into the leader that you are today
um so stanford has
been a key part of uh my career
certainly post-graduation but also
pre-graduation because i think as
someone mentioned
uh they tapped into the stanford network
uh during the deferral as well so
it was similar for me i think the
biggest piece for me has been
to be a more empathetic leader and to be
a more outcomes-oriented leader and what
i mean by that is
i think some of the classes um that both
the devonsa i think have
um highlighted around interpersonal
dynamics there's another one called the
art of soft coaching
that really um pushes
the students to think about what does it
mean to truly have one plus one equals
to three right and a big part of that is
listening a big part of that is
uh understanding and empathizing with
your team and
really creating the right sort of
motivations um and energies
to create exceptional outcomes and so
that's been something that i've
that i think about a lot on a daily
basis i've been lucky to work
with leaders from the gsb who who've
done that at much larger scale to see
them do it in action and learn that in
practice as well
that's been a big part of my learning of
how to be an empathetic leader
and then make sure that it pairs with
outcomes i think
uh the there are some exceptional
leaders
um from the gsb like john donahoe who
was the ceo of bain
uh he actually used to teach at the gsb
when i was there ended up
joining service now when
i graduated and i followed him and he's
been someone who sort of led
led from the front because he used to
teach a class called leadership
perspectives
at the gsb which taught how to drive
exceptional outcomes
with empathetic leadership and that's
sort of defined my thinking
both the gsb so very grateful for that
great thank you well i imagine our
attendees would be
very grateful if you would each maybe
provide some guidance
or some personal experiences about how
you approached
the application so in our information
sessions and our
our website we talk a lot about making
sure that you are
being authentic in your application and
taking the time to
write your application yourself uh and
take this opportunity to be reflective
uh you know reflecting on the
experiences that you've had so far
what matters to you and how the mba may
fit into what's next for you
so painting with a with very broad
strokes
i'm wondering if each of you could maybe
share a little bit about how you
approach
the application process yourself i know
we touched a little bit about choosing a
recommender but maybe a little bit about
how you decided to talk a little bit
about your experiences
how you approach the essays which i know
can be quite time consuming and
sometimes overwhelming for people so any
general advice
or if not straight up advice just
talking a little bit about your own
personal approaches
because i think it's important for
everyone to realize that there is no
one-size-fits-all piece of advice here
it really is each of you coming to this
uh in your own way so i'm wondering if
each of you could maybe share a little
bit about the approaches you took
because i suspect they're probably going
to be a little different and i think
it's important for people to realize
that that's okay
i'm happy to jump in here uh yeah the
first thing i'll say is just take any
advice from an alum
with a grain of salt because we also
don't know why we got in
for all we know what i think meat got me
into gsb is the thing i got in despite
uh that and so just take anything i say
with a grain of salt that said
um i think the big thing for me was like
really being authentic
in the essays and i know that sounds
somewhat trite but authentic
even to the point where it sometimes
felt generic of the things i was writing
like
on my essay to share for a second of
what mattered most to me it was
connections with other people and i
thought that was so ridiculously generic
that there was no way i could get in um
and it's funny because i know so many
classmates who wrote a similar essay
but it was true to them and so i would
say write what's true to you regardless
of what anybody else if that's the
most generic example in the world tell
it but tell it honestly and show why
that's true for you
if it's something uber specific that
nobody else in the world would pick like
pick that too
just really try to answer the question
as they're asking it because i think
that's what they're looking for
i love that um so similar to
what devin had shared earlier um i
didn't think i had a shot of getting in
um and so when i was approaching the
application process
i was looking at it as this huge
opportunity to just dig deep and
introspect
um and yeah as we said before it was all
upside
right it was this amazing structured um
reason to look back on my life to that
point
think about what gave me energy what i
cared about
um how i hoped to serve the world around
me um
and then yeah try to tell a story with
it um so
to that end just like very tactically
what i started
by doing was um actually creating like
an inventory
across academic experiences um
extracurriculars personal life
like you name it um of
the moments or the experiences that i
found most meaningful
or where i felt like my work was
meaningful um
and just started by casting a very wide
net and trying to like truly get to the
bottom
of what mattered most to me um and
so yeah i mean i think that maybe that's
not the most efficient process but um
i gained a lot from it and learned a lot
from it and so i guess distilling that
to like one message i would share with
you all is
i would really encourage you to look at
this application process
as just a huge opportunity um and as
a potential source of like joy and
exploration
um rather than something stressful
that's some really good advice to kevin
antimon anything else to add there
i i think it's very similar to what both
the devons have mentioned which is
um we don't know why we got in i think
it's it's it's a great exercise for self
introspection
the only one you know other lens that i
perhaps
use that was helpful for me is um
is to give some thought as devon
mentioned to what are your big hopes
aspirations and dreams that you're
trying to chase and you you may not know
what the specifics are i think someone
mentioned that in the q a
but at least you know like for me that
at a high level that was changing how
the future work is going to look like
and i didn't know how or when or in
which industry but having a point of
view on what your hopes aspirations
and greens are and then almost being
uh convinced that you're going to get
there no matter what
it's only that the gsb or the mba is
going to
accelerate your pathway there it's not
that you're not not going to get there
it's a
question of how fast and you know
business school and the gsb is a big
accelerant for that
i think once i had that point of view on
i think i was able to write much more
honestly
about what i'm going to do over the next
few years and really
and truly where the gsb can plug in and
help me and i
i think that made a big difference for
me i i i struggled
with my essays for weeks and then once i
had that sort of
realization and almost brashness i think
i actually wrote my essays in four hours
and so um that worked for me and
but i'm sure everyone's going to find
their own sort of unique
way to put their thoughts down on paper
and and make sure that's authentic for
you
absolutely well thank you all for that
hopefully that is helpful uh to those of
you who are getting ready or are working
on your applications
currently uh i see one of the questions
uh in the chat coming up about
you know why are you applying now i
think a couple of our panelists today
have mentioned that there's
there's only an upside here to apply in
your final year of undergrad and
it's a great opportunity to just you
know take that time to be introspective
now
and if you are not admitted uh as a
college senior there's
plenty of other opportunities in the
future further on into your career
uh certainly from our perspective at
stanford we welcome re-applicants every
year
uh unfortunately the reality for us is
uh one of the benefits of our program is
a
small intimate classroom experience but
as a result
it does mean that we can't admit
everyone who
is really wonderful every year and so
there's always options to apply again in
the future so always keep that in mind
speaking of looking ahead to the future
as you all think about your time
at stanford uh another question that
we're seeing a lot of is
what were the resources that you took
advantage of or were most helpful to you
in the program so uh let's maybe start
with
devin kelsey if there's something that
comes to mind whether it was a class a
a program uh anything that you found
really particularly valuable and then
david greenberg maybe we'll have you
because i know you're still on your
first year but maybe you can share what
you've found really helpful so far
yeah i'll use uh somewhat of a fun
narrative
um you know i i struggled a lot
throughout gsb trying to figure out what
i wanted to do
afterwards because i sort of realized i
was on a path that wasn't the right path
and i think a lot of the classes and
even the extracurriculars even just
chatting with classmates like being in a
community like that
is a big forcing function of really
asking yourself
why you're doing what you're doing and
you know there are a lot of people in my
class who seem to have it all figured
out like they seem to know where they
were going to work afterwards
i was never one of those students you
know there was actually a class taught
by tyra banks
that i took and absolutely loved and
there was a whole
assignment in the class where we had to
speak in front of the entire rest of the
class
about who we were and defining who we
are and it started out with like
two minutes and that was super easy
because you're telling your story
but then she doesn't tell you that it's
now going to go to 30 seconds and then
15 seconds and then a couple words
and as i was doing that that sort of
class and like doing that
with professors and my classmates was
like a really eye-opening example of
like one of those things of like
who am i really at my core and i think
that's just one of
hundreds of examples of like in the
class and out of the class
experiences that really contributed to
that sort of thinking
that helped me figure out what path i
wanted to be on yeah take my perspective
with a grain of salt because i'm still
still fresh but um i would say the two
things that have helped me most
in navigating these questions and
yeah developing those like strong
hypotheses
i've been one um the amazing career
center there are a few individuals there
that are just
so incredibly helpful um in taking what
from my perspective felt like
a mess of questions considerations um
ideas and helping me get really clear on
how to test those out um and to my
classmates
as devin was mentioning um it's just
like such a wonderful opportunity
to be able to sit down with people that
you know you like socially that you are
connecting with
and pick their brains about the work
they did
why they found it meaningful what
they're thinking about for the future
and it's kind of this incredible
opportunity to like
almost prototype several different
career paths like
you know in between classes um just
through those sorts of conversations
um so yeah those are the two that come
to mind for me great
thank you we had a question uh from
somebody who's interested in
understanding our curriculum
a little bit better so uh for those of
you who may not be aware
stanford graduate school of business is
on the quarter system uh and i think
they are interested in
understanding more about how that works
so for many of our attendees they may be
familiar with the semester system at
their undergrad
uh answer could you talk a little bit
about that quarter structure and maybe
some of the benefits
uh and or challenges that you found with
that format
yeah i mean my undergrad was a semester
um system so when i moved to the gsb it
was a little bit of a change
um i personally preferred the quarter
structure it's basically you know it is
it's as it sounds as three months of
curriculum
and coursework interspersed with some
breaks
um and the reason i really like the
quarter system is because i think
it forces you to really choose what
you're going to learn
over small chunks of time go deep into
it really focus on it
master it and then move on to something
else so i found that to be
a much more enriching rewarding learning
experience than a semester which is
usually six months and
can feel like it's taking forever and so
that's one piece of it the other piece
of it is the brakes and i think the
brakes are really special because i
think
the gsb community community does a lot
during those breaks as well i mean
you're welcome to take
time off but i think there's usually
immersion trips
work study trips um those kind of things
that are planned during these breaks
quarter after quarter that i took
advantage of so for instance i led a gsb
trip to india during one of the breaks
and i attended one in azerbaijan
and turkey and spain for two others
so really fun uh way for
the curriculum to sort of break out into
breaks that are quite meaningful
as well as keep a focused approach
towards learning
um so that was it and i think uh
christina if i'm not wrong
uh from a curriculum standpoint the
first year is uh is a set of
uh required baseline or uh
fundamental courses on accounting
finance marketing so
what have you and then the second year
has a ton more flexibility where you can
choose
uh courses at the gsb and outside the
gsb
and you almost have like a point system
where you can sort of choose some of the
classes
that you really want to pursue over the
next year
so great thank you and yes
that is still how things are working
today so i'm mindful of our time and
we're getting ready to wrap up
but we did have a couple of questions i
want to try to knock out real quick here
one is what kind of support can you
expect from the gsb during your deferral
well we are here from you we for you we
don't have a lot of
programming we've actually checked in
with our deferred students over the
years to check in
in terms of how much engagement you are
looking for
and most recently we did hear that
people are really interested in focusing
on the early stages of their career
but they do like the touch points and so
we do try to find
opportunities to invite our deferred
students to
conferences that are happening on campus
and other opportunities to engage with
current students and alumni
during that time we do invite you to
join us for the admitted student weekend
the year you are planning to matriculate
and enroll so we do hope that you'd be
able to join us for that
so hopefully that answers some of those
questions and with our final moments of
the session i'd love to just do a quick
round robin with our panel thank you all
for joining us today
uh devon greenberg i know you're still
just getting started but let's start
with you
and then we'll work our way around if
everyone could just share
a favorite memory moment experience uh
something that uh you know really sticks
with them as being something
quintessentially
stanford uh we'd love to hear that as we
wrap up today
so devon maybe we'll start and then
we'll we'll end with anshimon who's got
a little more
reflection uh time to think about
absolutely um i have a really vivid
memory standing up for me right now
um and so we we talked a bit about talk
earlier
uh the institution in which students
share their life stories to the class
and i will never forget when i got to
attend or watch the first talk of uh
that i had coached um and it had been
this really meaningful experience
of meeting with a classmate over five
sessions
and learning about her life learning
about what she cares about most in the
world
and supporting her and crafting that
story um
so getting to watch her get up there and
knock it out of the park was just like
such a gift and such a meaningful moment
of being like yes i'm at the gsb and
this is incredible
so yeah wonderful
devin yeah i actually had never even
left the country
before starting at gsb and so i got to
do my first ever
trip with some of my classmates and that
was the first of
about 10 or 12 times i left the country
during those two years
but going down to argentina and peru and
meeting some of my classmates for the
first time while having this
experience that was so outside my
comfort zone i think the fact that it
was so outside my comfort zone and there
was so much
learning and so much just newness all
crammed into two weeks
is a good analogy for the rest of the
program because there's just
so much over those two years it's like
drinking out of a fire hose because a
fire hydrant i guess the saying is
um because it's just so many things you
could be doing with your time
that it's it's wild that you even have
to choose sometimes between a and b
when there's so many great things you
could be doing at the school
auntie mom let's let's bring things on
yeah yeah i'm
i i'll just close out given that i have
the advantage of what five or six years
now
since graduation i think this was
unexpected when i was
uh a deferred admit coming into the gsb
but has been the biggest blessing
and memories set of memories for me uh
six years
after graduation is the the friendships
that i've made
at the gsb my best friends um
till this date or from the gsb i've seen
them get married i've seen them go
through some
life's most difficult situations
most recently one of my best friends
from the gsb
had to wind down his startup and
i saw him cry you know out on the street
in san francisco on the day he closes
his
uh uh shop down and then um
next thing we know a year down the line
we see him go out and raise
uh a series b from one of the top
venture capital fronts in the world and
seeing that journey with some of my
friends from the gsb has been
probably the biggest bus there in my
family um you know
five years now from business school and
that's always going to be special
so that's what i cherish the most at the
end of the day
well a big thank you again to our panel
i really appreciate you making time to
be with us today
and sharing your experiences both
applying
through deferred enrollment and also
sharing your experiences during your
time in the program
and thanks again to all of you for
joining us today expressing your
interest
in stanford and the deferred enrollment
program
we are here for you so if you do have
more questions feel free to reach out to
our office anytime
and we'll continue to be hosting events
like this again in the future so thank
you again
and have a wonderful day take care
[Music]
everyone